we just figured that everybody would
just would live at the beach house all
summer kind of like the real world but
then they were really living together
and they're really all having sex with
each other this is like a weird lab
experiment hello and welcome to reason
TV I'm Kennedy and tonight we are
celebrating the release of my book at
the Kennedy Chronicles the Golden Age of
MTV through rose-colored glasses and
it's a first-hand account of my time at
MTV in the 90s David not the president
of reason called it the kiss until a lot
of kissing but not a lot of other stuff
going on in the book but the reason that
I have a career at all I'm broadcasting
is because of the man that I'm sitting
here with right now his name is Andy
show and when I was an 18 year old
intern at a radio station here in Los
Angeles
he was the program director and for some
insane reason which I'll never quite
fully grasp he hired me to be a
part-time DJ and that's when my
broadcast career really began and then
Andy left and moved to MTV in the spring
of 1992 by the fall well he had acts to
everybody it was a bloodbath and they
needed new DJs and that's when you hired
me Andy so Andy Schon you are now the
president of revolt which is a 24-hour
Music Network that is going to launch
very soon doing it again yes doing it
again yeah
picking up where we left off in the late
90s I think yeah you know for the most
part so one of the most interesting
things that you said in the book because
we didn't interview I asked you some
questions about MTV at that time what
made it special and there has been on
Twitter and on my Facebook page some
argument as to whether or not the 90s
really were the Golden Age of MTV so you
can settle this do you think that was
the Golden Age or am I being too
optimistic yeah I mean maybe selfishly
because that was our era there but I
think that I'm such a pain in the ass
I'm gonna say yes I think for a lot of
reasons I mean it was you know there was
only one place to go to be influenced by
music in the 90s there was no Facebook
there's no social media MTV had become
so large by the 90s
influence was immense and so I think
that for artists I think artists would
say the 90s MTV was the the biggest
platform on earth you know to break was
that good for artists was it good for
them that that was really the the only
show in town and that there wasn't this
sort of democratic marketing with social
networking and YouTube and other outlets
for them yeah I think one of the reasons
that I'm not trying to plug my network
but they're one of the reasons that
we're coming back and doing this again
is we believe that artists having a
platform on TV is a great thing and they
all love having a million plays on
YouTube but to have some curation some
centralized selection of the best of the
best of the things that that really can
become popular on television is missing
today and there's still a place for it
it'll share the stage with many other
things today that we didn't share it
with in the 90s but yeah I think it is a
good thing I think it I think it artists
certainly had careers accelerated by it
it's much harder today to as long as
we're doing the right thing and you have
people who are picking good things you
know then then yeah and we had a lot of
artists at the time who were breaking
especially alternative acts who were
selling a million-plus records which it
doesn't happen nowadays I mean a lot of
bands go platinum selling singles and
and the music industry is very different
television is very different what was
them to be like when you inherited it in
1992 and you changed you really had a
big influence in the first couple years
but tell me what you got what you saw
when you got there and what were your
first big moves well MTV in 1992 was was
having still a bit of a hangover from
the the hair band and metal era and so
you know I got there and I felt like MTV
was playing the like the fifth rat video
or something you know sediment at the
bottom of the of the metal tank you know
it wasn't it wasn't that strong so I was
actually really fortunate and I think we
capitalized on alternative and
on rap music which we we work to rebrand
really hit as hip-hop on MTV with MTV
Jams so I kind of came in that year with
nevermind from Nirvana under one arm and
the chronic from dr. Dre under the other
arm and that became MTV Jams an
alternative nation and that brought you
know Nirvana Pearl Jam you know and
Chili Peppers and you know Tupac and
Biggie and all that to the channel in a
bigger way because we created vehicles
and those programs to to really bring
that music more to the mainstream and
that pushed out the last vestiges of the
the hair band era except for Jon Bon
Jovi you're still around today still
around right no and you know and and and
much respect to him because he really
stole it but still still relevant but
for the most part everybody you know was
pushed out ya Bon Jovi played the
iHeartRadio Music Festival last year you
know which is a huge seminal music
festival that kind of does what MTV
sought to do yeah and how did you do I
mean how did you balance because when I
got there I remember that n Vogue was
huge and Nirvana and Pearl Jam were
massive but how did you get hip hop and
arm be an alternative and you know
different varieties of rock to exist in
the same place and get the same audience
of people excited by it was that a
challenge yeah it was a challenge in it
but what's interesting today is you know
you have Twitter as a one of the guys
that works at my company today says
Twitter is is our dance floor you know
because we actually can do something and
then you can get a reaction right away
you know in social media back then you
know we didn't really know we had a
switchboard people would call the MTV
switchboard if they liked or didn't like
something usually if they didn't like
something and we would do periodic
research focus groups and things but I
would say I think we had a good handle
on on the pulse of what that generation
wanted at that time but we couldn't have
really known like you could know today
but what I would say that we were the
national pop music channel of record and
so we had no choice but to play in a
particular quarter hour I remember we'd
be playing you know Celine Dion's you
know my heart will go on and Nirvana
and you know in vogue or something in
the same 15 minutes and it's because we
could like a top 40 station so those
things didn't always meld real well
together but it was the beginning of
what we're experiencing today which is
sort of no genre barriers definitely
there you know there's a you can't
really mix for the most part country
with with hip hop or hard rock or
alternative but you know popular music
the most popular 200 singles or whatever
mixed together you know it's you should
you know you know what's on kids iPods
today you know there's a there's a mix
of all kinds of genres yeah and and so
much more thing that we did that to a
that's one of the things I'm proud of is
it
I came to MTV personally with a
knowledge of alternative music from
k-rock where we work together and I left
there with this vast knowledge of music
across all these genres and today I
still love all those genres like a lot
of people who grew up okay one of the
most interesting things and because MTV
was so powerful and so important to
record labels and it was still this
priceless real estate how did you guys
decide what videos to put on because I
know there was a department I don't even
know if it exists anymore to MTV I don't
know how much music they play during the
day but it was called talent and artist
relations yeah and that was the the
nucleus like the power nucleus at MTV
that record labels desperately wanted to
penetrate so they could get their videos
on in regular rotation how did you guys
choose what music to play one yeah it
was called talent nurse relations and
then there was also music programming
and when I got there I was the head of
music programming and there was also
talent are still Asians and they thought
that the balance of power was too big to
have one department in charge of the
music so it was a good democratic
process and I said the democratic
process doesn't really work and the
record companies who and the artists and
the managers who at that time the power
of MTV was so great that we essentially
had customer service reps for the record
companies that would then represent the
music department that was looking at the
research and the audience and deciding
what to play and I said these are like
people with a exotic sports car who want
to talk to the mechanic not the customer
service rep so let's combine them so
that the record industry can go directly
to the people making those decision
so we did that so that's sort of a long
way around but that department is so the
music department at MTV was the one that
you know picked the videos and there was
a process where they got submitted and
we had a lunch every week and we looked
at the new videos and there were
typically anywhere from about 25 to 40 a
week Wow
that would come in and we would look at
them for a couple of hours it's a huge
number yep yeah nowadays contemplate
that many song probably not but that
process we would look at anything that
we had acquired that had come in that we
could potentially play and we'd watch
them and we wouldn't watch them all the
way through there sometimes it was
obvious it would be zero percent chance
we're playing that you know and it would
just come off you know what's an example
of something that you guys really
surprised by the just electrified the
room that you weren't expecting you're
like oh we have to play that you know
what comes to mind is there were times
when you're just looking for cuz it is
TV so it's music but it's also it was
television and I remember it was the
beginning of the summer and this video
came in and it was I was just kind of
personally looking for something that
felt like summer and was fun and it was
challenging the 90s for MTV sometimes
because a lot of the alternative music
that was so popular it wasn't great TV
necessarily it wasn't the pop music of
the late 90s or early 2000s that was
very popular it was a lot of they called
shoegazing rock you know grunge and and
I remember saying we need to call the
industry we need to call a meeting we
need to have an intervention and say no
more wet basements with a swinging bear
light bulb in a video you know because
it was like yep it was like one more
mark bugging me with like the wet floor
in the basement I think there's hot
water heater over there's a lamp and
there's nothing you know so there was a
lot of that but I remember Coolio
Fantastic Voyage oh yeah okay a guy came
in and it was just this video when no
one had ever heard of him yeah they were
getting out of the trunk of the car or
something and it was and I wish I could
now remember the original track but it
was a you know it was a what it was a
remake of it you know there was a track
from a popular 70 song and and I said
that this feels like summer and it was
like probably May or June I said we need
let's just put that on
everyone was kind of like yeah why not
it's a good song it was because it was a
well-known hook you know and we put
Coolio on that was the beginning of
Coolio it was literally just saying I
like that that feels like summer you
know that's great yeah it was on the
radio or anything I don't think at that
time was just so that we did we were
able to do that you know from time to
time but we did take our work as you
know really really seriously you know
that music department of the 90s at MTV
some of the best debates and most
thoughtful passionate conversations I've
ever experienced were in the meeting the
next day which was the actual music
meeting we took those videos and then
the next day we would go in and we would
debate what came off of this show and
that show what came off of headbangers
ball what was going into alternative
nations what was going on MTV Jams what
was going in regular rotation what was
going up in rotation down in rotation
and those were passionate debates that
were amazingly fun and powerful to be
part of and we took her workplace
seriously used to say hey we're shaping
the way America rocks you know let's get
in there and do this you know and like
astronauts you know kind of do it but we
really took the mission seriously I
tried to do well because we knew about
the power that we had and one of the
things that you talked about in the book
that I wrote about in two chapters was
the MTV beach house yeah because you
wanted to get out of the studio you guys
had to refurbish the studio so we had to
get out yeah you know for practical
purposes but also you wanted to bring
kind of a Spring Break look the entire
summer and have a party going all summer
long something that looked visually like
summer when you turn on the TV so tell
me how did the beach house come to me
well the dilip one of the dilemmas for
MTV was and I was brought in right after
the 10th anniversary from a background
in radio programming to try to figure
out how to how to get the channels
ratings up and it was a short-form
network so just like CNN or The Weather
Channel
we're playing short pieces of content
4-minute pieces of content so an hour
was like 12 shows on MTV it was 12
videos versus a narrative you know of
you know the competition we had on TBS
would be you know a rerun of 90210 or
something and it had a story arc and it
would carry people through the hour once
you got invested in a story well we had
a hard time with 12 stories an hour to
get rating so
MTV and ratings didn't go so well
together the novelty of videos had worn
off so we had to figure out ways to make
them interesting again and to get people
to watch them so kids were you know had
the remote in their hand and they would
see a video they didn't like and there's
a that sucks and then they would go to
an increase in the larger lap around you
know cable or satellite to find you know
to find you know you know something else
and then come back an hour to later so
we had to get them to put the remote
down and watch things they didn't like
and be waiting for things they did like
so that was what sort of smoke and
mirrors long-form programming and that's
what the packaging was of MTV Jams or
alternative nation or the beach house
which was kind of the in many ways I
think the king of all of them because it
was not John recipie it was just a place
to go hang with MTV and you know our
strategy worked
you know kids would put the remote down
and say that video sucks that video is
cool that video sucks but I want to see
Kennedy in the Snapple hot tub with
Coolio you know after this or the slim
jim tug of war or whatever we had so it
was a product placement paradise oh yeah
but no I remember the Slurpee slide
7-eleven sponsored the Slurpee slide it
was literally and Michael Blum who was
the executive producer of VHS he's here
but he can attack that we had a giant
slip and slide that went down the the
sloping grass at the Malibu beach house
yeah it was covered in Slurpee yeah and
it was so much fun yeah but it almost
made you feel wrong because no I
remember bloom he used to wear it like a
big Tiki or son used to big actually or
maybe I'm supposed to say because it was
a no one supposed to know that I was
actually him but the Tiki God or
whatever it was but yeah so that worked
great because and I remember the day
that I fought hard to bring the beach
house to MTV because it was a commitment
to leave our studios and to do something
differently but I remember the day that
the beach house launched we were in the
office
it came on for the first time and you
just saw the blue sky and the ocean
there and in Quogue in the Hamptons and
and the kids on the pool deck you know
and the music playing and it was the
grind probably which is our dance show
at that time that came on my arrack New
York nice from real world that's right
so it came on and
you could feel it on the 24th floor in
the middle of Times Square tower
building and yet and and and a number of
people you know crowded around the
office and came down and talked about
immediately how they said I bet we're
gonna get the numbers you know from this
and I really I remember getting an email
or not email put in heavy mail and a
note a hand note and one of those little
envelopes to the string around it that
came in in a departmental mail back then
and it was from Tom Freston our chairman
his who would suit circled the ratings
the next day it came out at 3:00 the
next day or whatever well done tom you
know and we had doubled our ratings you
know did not care for the doubled
ratings mrs. Preston
avi Chows that's right just down the
street from the first MTV beach out that
we got kicked out of so not only was
everyone there in their twenties and
single and humping each other yeah but
we were also loud and yeah everyone the
entire staff is living in the beach
house yeah I mean these are the things
I'm thinking these are the things that
don't make it back to Manhattan that you
don't realize so the idea of MTV going
out to a beach house and packaging the
music videos around the hosts and guests
in a really fun fantasy place completely
worked and it proved out in the ratings
proved out with the advertisers I think
it made more money for Viacom than
Titanic and Forrest Gump combined over
the years I mean it probably made a
billion dollars and skittles skittles
money and Pizza Hut and everything else
which is great I'm really proud of it
because I definitely think it'd it
definitely preserved my my job for a
long time I can still dine out on being
the beach house guy I it's also it's
where my career almost came to an end
because I can't remember exactly but I
want to say that it was I I came back
from the first really nice vacation I
ever had at like a tropical destination
feeling all successful and everything
I've never been to a high-end vacation I
came back I was so relaxed I got off the
up this is the true story I got off the
elevator ding and then Kurtz tefik who
works with it worked with us said for
essence looking for you for instance
looking for you serious has a what what
what you know and I
I believe he I'll have to ask him but I
believe he I went into his office and he
said shown your dirt and like I'm dirt
what are you talking about it was all
about the beach house and this problem
with the beach house and the craziness
that had happened in his town it is
summer town and Tom's an amazing amazing
guy and it would not be like him to be
troubled by anything like that he would
he would we move down the street and and
you said that that the people who run
the beach house had lost their minds and
completely gone rope well this is what
it had this is the part that so it
worked on TV what I didn't think through
was the fact that we just figured that
everybody would just would live at the
beach house all summer kind of like the
real world but then they were really
living together and they were really all
having sex with each other yeah and with
each other's each of each other's each
other's and it became a real problem and
I got a call after a couple of weeks
saying this is like a weird lab
experiment and all the employees are
it's not even I don't even know if it's
legal if there's an HR problem or what
I'm like I didn't even think of that and
then you know there aren't any really
any hotels out in the Hamptons you know
so we took over every every
bed-and-breakfast every motel room we
could find all went to empty the
employees for the whole summer so after
that yeah we figured it out yeah yeah
all right so one of the stories that
that you and I are so intimately
involved in which which is an entire
chapter in the book yeah it's a it
should be called the miracle I didn't
get fired and that was that that was
which time when you when you really have
you know go to bat to save my job
after the Rudy Giuliani incident yeah
which Roseanne is on stage hosting the
1994 Video Music Awards yeah she made
some comment on stage that I had had
oral sex with Rush Limbaugh and then
Bill Bellamy and the mayor of New York
City the new mayor Rudolph Giuliani who
lobbied to get the VMAs back to New York
we're all up on the balcony and we're
soliciting votes for the viewers Choice
Award and as we go live our faces go on
the big screen at Radio City
everyone starts booing no one boos Bill
Bellamy and so I panicked and start
licking the microphone as though I'm
having marital relations with my mouth
yeah my [ __ ] yeah and the crowd starts
like yeah and I just think it's a great
moment but I have a way to get a laugh
yeah yeah but the problem was I was
standing next to the mayor of New York
City on live television
my calm yeah MTV Networks executive yeah
and I didn't realize in the moment that
that was a big deal but apparently at
what what yeah it was it was yeah it was
one of the one of the several times that
I had to answer for your behavior
I started in September November you were
like can you please come into my office
and you played me from your voicemail a
call from standards and practices person
the switchboard operator who said can I
use a bad word okay
who said hi I got a call at 3:00 in the
morning from several angry viewers
because apparently Kennedy said
[ __ ] I didn't I said
mothertrucker uh-huh yeah that's good
it's a good way to do it like did you
did you say [ __ ] man yeah yeah
right here yeah come on you have to say
that yeah yeah but the Giuliani incident
from your perspective what happened well
you know in one hand it's one of the
reasons that we're here today and that
you know people remember who Kennedy is
and they can't remember all of the VJs
you know there you go
the book in stores now or Tuesday or
whatever it is is is because you were a
polarizing figure on there okay so so
people remember so events like that
actually you know while you didn't do it
on purpose in that case it those things
helped you in a way you know but I don't
remember exactly I know I know that it
went up to Sumner Redstone
of course who was the chair you know
still is the chairman of Viacom owns MTV
and I had a meeting in a conversation we
had we discussed you know whether or not
you know you could stay or you needed to
go and it was not our way to let people
go
we had a motto at MTV they may still
have it I don't know but we had a motto
that we'd rather be be sorry than safe
and so we did a lot of apologizing at
MTV and that was another one of the
times we apologized and we got through
it I think you wrote a letter to
everyone the next yeah and I didn't
realize what a big deal with so I walked
outside yeah and I saw your face and you
gave me this look like what are you
doing to me right what are you doing
yeah there's a joke I said to Tom like
hey it was nice working with you and he
looked at me with such active contempt
oh yeah yeah and then I got a call from
my manager who was watching the show
live and was like do you realize the
amount of damage control this is going
to take a second I'm writing a letter
right now that I'm going after FedEx
right home Preston oh I know cuz they
worry about advertisers and all that and
if you think about it the fact that we
there was a meeting that took place in a
corporate setting to discuss you licking
a microphone with the mayor you know and
we had to have like you know a meeting
about it it's pretty funny at the end of
the day a 20 no it's funny now yeah it's
funny no we smooth it over yeah I know
you have to smooth it over that it over
because another executive an MTV Lorne
Levine yeah went to a bar where you were
all summiting at the bar and tom was
very angry and she made a joke about it
yeah that went over like a fart in
church but we talked about that I mean I
think it's important to say that we
talked about the the the the Hamptons
and Tom Freston being mad we talked
about that Giuliani thing the reality is
greatest boss ever and didn't get mad
very often it was incredibly supportive
of everything we did yeah I mean you
know for real
so yeah he always called me back yeah I
would call him just for fun just to see
if I could get him to call yeah he would
always call me back he'd be on a private
plane with you take your call right now
right yep so what do you take from MTV
into revolt because you're starting this
24-hour music channel will you mold it
after your time at MTV what successes
you take and how do you change things
especially in light of the way
technology and media are married now
yeah I think in some ways we'll take
some of them but the parts from the 90s
that that were important to us I mean
our commitment to artists and breaking
artists that same kind of passion that
we had in those music meetings we have
at revolt today it's starting up we do
you know similar it's same kind of style
what's different today is we don't have
that lunch you can't have that organized
lunch and those 40 videos and go through
them and and set them up like a chess
game you know for the next month of your
channel because that stuff's being
posted on YouTube and going out you know
every day a new interesting content by
artists is being made and put on YouTube
right now and out in social media or
Vimeo or whatever it is being you know
tweeted and everything so back when
we're at MTV we had that supreme power I
might have liked that Coolio video
instead I like that but there's no room
for it this week because there's only 60
minutes in an hour
you can only play so much so we might
say I like that let's keep an eye on
that maybe play that in a couple weeks
you can't do that today because somebody
else is gonna beat you to it
someone's gonna build an audience or an
affinity for that somewhere else so we
actually have to make our playlist every
day every hour we have to break into
programming when something cool gets
posted or something new comes in so that
is different so to be relevant to an
audience today on television and we're
going out on Time Warner Cable and
Comcast there's a real industrial sized
cable channel in addition to our other
platforms to be relevant today we've got
to be live we got to be connected to
social media will be live many hours a
day so the part of MTV that I always
fought for coming from radio was was
live you know one of the last things we
did was launch the Time Square studio
you know in the in the fall of 97 I
think when TV is live it's more exciting
you know just like radio you know it's a
you know a live show versus a
pre-recorded show you just have a
different feeling
and things can go wrong and our job at
revolt is going to be to be really the
global place for the conversation around
music and very much a respectful
journalistic way so to to really give
artists a platform again to take TV back
for artists who don't have that place
anymore
I mean MTV said goodbye to New York when
they closed down TRL I saw at Carson
Daly and and Kid Rock go to the window
and Carson said say goodbye to New York
you know and Kid Rock said goodbye to
New York and and it felt weird because
that commitment to music was shutting
down and so there are a lot of places to
find music today we're gonna be a place
where we'll be dedicated to it 24 hours
a day seven days a week and there really
isn't a place like that on TV today with
that kind of commitment is that failing
on MTV's part no I think MTV's MTV's and
incredibly successful may be more
successful than ever today and they're a
mix of many things they're really a
I guess they're maybe they call
themselves a youth culture Network and
when we were there we started that plan
at the 10 spot and more long-form
programming and animation and all that
absolutely yeah we started that trend
and it built ratings like the beach
house was able to do that and then over
time the balance was upset at MTV and
they they went maybe too far in one
direction but I can't say so because
they've been very successful with the
strategy they've had and they have a
huge audience and they've been that you
know they've been very successful so
well I know what we're doing and we're
gonna try and play music on TV again and
I know a lot of people I host the
morning music show and are desperate for
music to be back on TV so you're giving
it to them you gave me my first and
second break you gave me to career so
thank you mate yeah well maybe we'll do
it again alright okay so you can you can
read all about any shown the book is
dedicated to it and there's an entire
inner thank you for the dedication by
the way it's very sweet of you
it was totally unnecessary it was very
sweet of you though needs a lot it was
riki rachtman well thank you thank you
frankly you've got a nicer car
thank you Amy and thank you for watching
you can check out more videos music and
otherwise always a reason TV
you